as former NSA contractor Edward Snowden
revealed in 2013 the US government
routinely spies on its own citizens I
sitting my desk certainly had the
authorities to to wiretap anyone from
you or your accountant to a federal
judge to even the president if I had a
personal email and they lied about it
does the NSA collect any type of data at
all on millions or hundreds of millions
of Americans no sir it does not
not wittingly four years after the
Snowden leaks the government is still
collecting Americans private information
the NSA claims it ended bulk collection
of domestic phone calls but the agency
still operates several far-reaching
domestic spying programs now there's a
way to end this unconstitutional
practice the NSA gets its authority to
spy on Americans under section 702 of
the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act but the law expires this year after
it hits its five-year sunset and
lawmakers will soon be debating whether
to renew it for another five or even
permanently here's why it's vital they
let it lapse and don't renew 702
[Music]
the Attorney General and director of
national intelligence may authorize the
targeting of persons reasonably believed
to be located outside the United States
to acquire foreign intelligence
information that's the text of the
controversial section 702 it's a statute
that allows the government to collect
communications between foreign targets
and Americans without obtaining a
warrant without showing probable cause
or really any level of suspicion of
wrongdoing the reason that section 702
supposedly is useful is so that the NSA
can spy on foreigners abroad without
having to get a search warrant every
time they want to open a wiretap the
problem is they're actually using it to
spy on Americans US officials have
admitted 702 isn't just about spying on
foreigners in the run-up to authorizing
it former NSA had Michael Hayden even
said communications with one end in the
United States are the ones that are most
important to us government officials
when they try to defend the breadth of
section 702 surveillance and the fact
that communications of Americans are
being obtained without a warrant point
to the fact that the target has to be a
foreigner overseas and that any
collection of Americans information is
incidental we hear that word over and
over it's just incidental communications
incidentally collected incidentally
acquired under the so called incidental
collection issue incidental us person
collection incidentally incidentally
that word has a particularly GLE meaning
which is somewhat in tension with the
common sense meaning I think anybody
listening to that statement oh our
communications of Americans are picked
up only incidentally would get the sense
that the government's not really
interested in those communications that
those communications are picked up in
some way almost accidentally and that's
not the case at all
there are safeguards in the law intended
to limit the powers granted by section
702 the government may not intentionally
target any person located in the United
States and variations on that theme
but the Snowden leaks revealed the
existence of two massive domestic
surveillance programs operating under
702 under the prism program the
government will approach Google or
Microsoft or one of those companies and
say here is a target here's the target's
email address we want all of the stored
emails that you have for that target
then there's upstream surveillance the
NSA forced telecom providers to install
surveillance equipment along their
physical networks so that can capture
millions of emails and messages in real
time kind of like a wiretap on everyone
who uses the internet from there they
created massive searchable databases
think Google but for searching the
private emails of American citizens the
FBI routinely searches through databases
that include communications that have
been picked up through section 702
surveillance whenever it conducts an
investigation whether a national
security investigation or an ordinary
criminal investigation the FBI of course
is not a foreign intelligence
organization it's a domestic law
enforcement organization so we I mean we
know that FBI is using what is supposed
to be a foreign intelligence system for
domestic law enforcement not only were
agents capturing and reading messages
between Americans and foreign targets
they were capturing messages written by
Americans about foreign targets imagine
you wrote an email to a friend and
mentioned something about a suspected
terrorist that you read about in the
news in the body of the message under
702 government agents can read that
email if you're collecting
communications not just to a target not
just from a target but communications
that merely mention a target or
information associated with that target
you are much more likely to pick up
entirely innocence
that are of no interest to you not to
mention you're more likely to pick up
communications that are wholly domestic
between two Americans the NSA ended
about collection after being ordered to
examine the practice by the courts but
the agency has other tricks for
surveilling Americans under 702 Universe
targeting is when the government's
actual intent is to get information
about a particular known American but
instead they choose a target who is a
foreigner overseas presumably knowing
that the American will be in contact
with that person
reverse targeting is technically
prohibited under 702 so agents use a
workaround called a backdoor search I
think that backdoor searches are a form
of reverse targeting now backdoor
searches are when the government goes
into the court says we are not targeting
any particular known Americans we have
no interest in any particular known
Americans our only interest here is in
the foreign targets collects the data
based on that representation and then
immediately goes looking through the
data for the information of particular
known American the NSA even has cutesy
code names for some of these abuses love
int is the cutesy codename for spying on
your ex at the NSA it's done enough that
they actually have a nickname for spying
on your ex even the secretive FISA
courts which oversee the intelligence
agencies have questioned the methods by
which the NSA has exploited the law to
expand its powers documents recently
made public revealed that the FISA
judges accused the NSA of displaying an
institutional lack of candor and
ignoring a very serious Fourth Amendment
issue when it hid the fact that its
agents were knowingly surveilling us
targets so when the FISA Court says that
there's a culture of non-compliance at
NSA that doesn't come as a shock to us
at all what does come as a shock to us
is when NSA director Rogers sits in
front of the Senate Intelligence
Committee and says there's never been an
intentional violation have there been
any instances involving a deliver
or intentional compliance violation at
Mirage errs not that I'm aware the
Office of the Director of National
Intelligence has made public some
transparency reports and the most recent
release indicates that the government is
currently surveilling more than 94,000
people or organizations with techniques
authorized under 702 and how many
Americans communications are read under
702 we don't know for sure the Office of
the Director of National Intelligence
last year
promised EF F and a number of other
civil liberties groups a number an
estimate of how much data that is purely
domestic gets swept up and then just a
couple of weeks ago the new DNI dan
coates went back on that promise there
were extensive efforts on the part of I
learned on the parts of NSA to try to
come to to get get you an appropriate
answer we were not able to do that
Trump campaign officials and associates
themselves seem to have been caught in
the surveillance dragnet when they
allegedly talked to and about Russian
targets yet administration officials
have made it clear they want 702 renewed
without any further changes the fact
that the Trump administration can out of
one side of its mouth complain about
about collection under 702 and on the
other say we must you know snap our
fingers and and reauthorize it possibly
even without a sunset which is something
that we've heard coming out of the White
House and Capitol Hill is is
mind-boggling
if the government is conducting
surveillance to find out who you talk to
and and if you're an American and you
have a Fourth Amendment reasonable
expectation of privacy
then this should not be done through
programmatic surveillance warrantless
surveillance it's time that a
warrantless collection of Americans
communications stopped and that means
not reauthorizing 702 the American
people never even got to hear a debate
when these programs began in secret
under President Bush and only started to
hear about it under President Obama
after Edward Snowden leaked information
that the government never wanted us to
hear it's time to put a real check on
the growing vast powers of our
intelligence agencies while we still can
[Music]